hi I'm CBS News contributor Jamie wax
and we are here on Facebook live with
the great Paul Reiser to thrill yes
contributor that's right it's a very
kind I contribute you contribute I
contribute not subtracting you're giving
back for you sometimes some days I feel
like I'm contributing I had the pleasure
of sitting down with you at the comedy &
magic yes very important place to you in
Hermosa Beach a couple of months ago yes
for CBS this morning and we talked about
your wide-ranging career and the
incredible fact that you took you
basically took 15 years off of doing
stand-up and almost everything else in
show business yeah I was kind of staying
I was staying about I was I was writing
and doing stuff but I was mostly under
the radar behind the scenes and I was
writing a lot of things and then for
some reason there is some sort of
synchronicity that when I started going
back and doing stand-up again all these
terrific other opportunities came up I
don't know the connection but there
seems to be something there definitely
seems to be something because like
Howard Stern used to call himself the
king of all media I have to say when I'm
looking at 2017 you are kind of the king
of all streaming platforms I go wider
than that I'd say it's it's the year of
me Reiser and then a year you go to
Chinese restaurants you see a monkey and
then me this is my year but it really is
okay let's talk about this you've got
red oaks which is if you haven't seen
this it's a terrific kind of an homage
yeah 1980s Shack style comes great it's
a really sweet there was all the
Caddyshack Meets The Graduate that's
right coming of age and I yeah and I was
just a hired hand there I got to just
come in and play with other people's
words so season two came out this fall
on Amazon season three sitting three
came out this fall on a Mazur and then
on another streaming platform Netflix
you got a little series that some people
might know called stranger things yes
yes I helped them out a little bit there
yeah we were just nominated for an
ensemble a SAG Award fronts honorable
cast and it it hurts me a little bit I
got to share my award with all the kids
you know anything but listen if you got
to do it I want to help you you were
nominated for so many Emmys throughout
the course of Mad About You
which you created or you wrote the theme
song to this was that show was really
your baby and oh yeah yeah yeah
is it is it still a thrill at this point
to come back get this attention and then
be nominated for a SAG Award you know
it's just it's just fun to actually be
doing fun work mean it's interesting
stranger things is such a kind of
different world than I would ever
imagined myself or create for myself so
that some genius has figured out and
there's Abby come play with us that's
that's the fun part the fun part is
getting to play you know and red oaks is
a different world and then there's
Johnny was it was a real thrill for me
because that was something that was
original idea my buddy David Simon and I
and we created this thing into I'm not
in it but then just to move the parts
around and get these great actors we've
Jane levy and Tony Danza and Ian Nelson
and recreate this world and then to
finally see it you know it's on Hulu and
I took a long time to get this show out
there and for a whole bunch of reasons
so that that's really the most
gratifying part for me let's talk about
that because we've got we've got
stranger things on Netflix we've got red
oaks on Amazon and as you mentioned
you've got there's Johnny which is
another passion project for you really
1972 tonight's show when all of America
was tuning into Johnny every night what
is it about that show that era that
attracted you well it was uh you know it
was in the air I mean you just knew and
especially if you had an inkling that
you was some day want to be a comedian
it's like or maybe that was what helped
form it we you know Johnny was it and
you didn't have as many options you just
there were a couple of talk shows but
Johnny was the king and 72 was when his
show moved from New York out to
California and then it kind of took on
this bigger than life thing and it
really was look like the place to be so
the idea of our show was well what if
you were just a kid who knew nothing and
suddenly landed in that world and you
show business and sex drugs and rock and
roll 72 and we get to use the actual
clips from the car actual cars and shows
we had the cooperation of the Carson
company so you're watching it in the go
looks like it must be real because
there's Johnny that's how we got the
name and and and I'm so proud of the way
it came out because it really it does
seem real it's all fiction the
characters if they
the stories and it's about these two
young people finding their way but the
backdrop of Johnny Carson and and
getting to see all these great tastes of
him again is really a thrill for for
those of us who remember are you getting
feedback from people who it's it's
igniting nostalgia for them yeah you
know Johnny had such a big place in
everybody's heart and part of our lives
you know he put you to bed you went to
bed watching Johnny Carson so even
though yes it's available you can get
the DVDs you can watch a live shows but
you don't always do it so just to have
just these little tastes of him in there
it brings back a time and it was it
wasn't really an easy time but it seems
simple or somehow looking back and and
the story about the the the lead
characters is sort of a timeless thing
it's just people finding themselves but
in this particularly tense intense
hotbed of a time so yeah you know it
works on a lot of levels levels is
there's a bit of nostalgia but it's
really feels to me feels very
contemporary and cool how much is
working on this show bring back your
your first time on Carson as a comedian
well you know what a lot of what's fun
and looking at these clips I haven't
seen them in 40 years and you go right
back to I remember I remember seeing
George Karl and I remember staying up to
watch that one
there's Albert Brooks and yeah for me
for comics at about my generation that
that was the goal you get on Johnny and
and you play that in your head for years
way before your should be even thinking
about it go I'm gonna come out and
through that curtain and you picked your
that's that curtain is so iconic that
every comedian notes yeah I want to step
through that curtain and into show
business well I hope everybody will
watch it's a it's a retu that's all I
asked by the way I got an early look at
it and I was very lucky yes you did
share it a little bit tell us some other
folks but it's there's Johnny streaming
right now right now on Honolulu and
you've got red oaks on Amazon as we said
and you've got a course stranger things
too I also have some pictures of myself
in high school whatever you want to see
I've got it all covered no matter what
platform yes Paul Reiser is there the
holidays are a great time to binge why
not just binge Paul Reiser the entire
time that's all I would ask all right
nice to see you
to see you again thanks guys